here's what I see the first thing I'm
looking at is the file structure and
from that I can tell that we probably
have two views one thing is called app
view and one thing is called to do view
now I'm choosing to explore my file and
folder structure here in sublime text
but you could also do it here in the
finder it's just not necessarily as easy
to see everything at once here I can
open up multiple folders at once and see
all of the files inside now I can infer
from the naming of these views that this
one is the view for the entire
application and this one is the view for
each to-do item and speaking of to-do
items we also have a model for our to-do
to do j/s now you may also remember that
we also have things called collections
at least that's what they're called here
in knock-out we called them observable
arrays and from the name I can infer
that this is probably just a collection
of to do models so we've got two views
we've got a model for each to do we've
got a collection of to do's and then we
also have this router thing and if you
remember from before although we haven't
used them in this class routers are just
like views but for the URL instead of
the page itself
now there's also this weird thing called
Bower now what the heck is that
well one simple way to find out is to
Google it if we search for Bower we get
Bower dot IO and we click it says Bower
a package manager for the web so if
you've never heard of Bower before you
can just read this web page and it'll
give a high-level overview of what it is
it says websites are made of lots of
things frameworks libraries assets
utilities and rainbows Bower manages all
of these things for you now I'm not
going to get into any more depth of what
Bower is but feel free to explore it on
your own suffice it to say it keeps
track of all of the various libraries
that we're using now what libraries are
we using let's go back to our editor and
we'll look at all of the things that
Bower is holding on to for us we've got
backbone
we've got backbone dot local storage we
have jQuery we have to do MVC common and
we have underscore
now let's make a couple guesses of
course you can google these things and
make those guesses a definite but I'm
going to guess that because to do MVC
is a project where the same app is built
in all these different frameworks to do
MVC common is just going to be a bunch
of assets that are used in all of those
various projects a CSS file a base
javascript file and it looks like a
background dot PNG those are just
resources that are common to all of our
to do MVC projects we're only working
with one so we don't have to really
worry about what that is now if you
explore a little bit further you'll find
that that base dot CSS file is the only
CSS file that we're going to be caring
about if you need to make any changes to
the CSS you can feel free to do that and
in fact if you open it up and you look
through there have been some changes
that have been made by me specifically
so we can get ready to do all of the
various things that we're going to add
to the project let's take a moment to
look at all of these others jQuery we've
talked about jQuery before jQuery is a
Dom manipulation library it also lets
you make Ajax calls to servers and has
some good utilities if you need an
overview of jQuery go ahead and take a
look at the website and if you need more
in-depth jQuery feel free to take a look
at our course on it
we've got backbone and backbone dot
local storage now who knows what
backbone is maybe you do but maybe you
don't
so let's google it backbone Jas aha
backbone Jas gives structure to web
pages by providing models collections
and views so it looks like this is our
model view whatever this is our
organizational library backbone Jas if
we go back to our code there's one more
underscore so what's underscore well
once again we can hop over and google it
underscore Jas underscore Jas is a
JavaScript library that provides a whole
mess of useful functional programming
helpers without extending any built-in
objects blah blah blah blah blah so it
looks like underscore just gives us a
bunch of utility functions which makes
it easier to write JavaScript now they
talk about functional programming that's
beyond way beyond the scope of this
course but even if you don't get into
functional programming at all underscore
Jess does have a whole mess of useful
functions and sometimes it's nice to
include underscore rather than
reinventing the wheel over and over
let's explore a little bit more if we go
to our index.html file the page that
gets loaded will notice a couple of
interesting things here we're loading
our CSS based CSS exactly what we were
looking at before and if you go to the
very bottom of the page you'll see all
of the script tags loading to do NBC
command based is jQuery underscore
backbone backbone dot local storage
which I'm going to guess is a plug-in
for backbone to make it work with local
storage and then all of our JavaScript
files to do in the models collection
both views the routers and app Das and
if we look around a little bit more
we'll notice these peculiar script tags
normally you have Script without a type
or with a type of text slash JavaScript
in this case it says text slash template
so these represent snippets of HTML that
our JavaScript can use to display things
in our app for example item template is
going to be the template for displaying
a to-do item if we ever wanted to make
changes to the way our to-do items
render this would be a good place to do
it because this is the template that
they render based off of so let's return
to those questions really quickly the
library whose name starts with a U is
underscore the organizational library
that's used to separate our concerns is
backbone how many views do we see two
views app view and to do view and
hopefully this all makes enough sense
that we are comfortable moving on